Alors, pour le slogan?
Oui ! Alors, euh...
"Seb... c'est... bien" !
- "Seb, c'est b..."
- Oui.
Mais c'est génial !! Waouh !!!!!!
Pour le slogan ?
- Euh... "C'est bien" ?
- Ça on l'a déjà fait pour Seb.
"C'est..." ...euh... "C'est beau, c'est..."
...euh... "C'est Bosh"...??
"C'est bien, c'est beau, c'est Bosh" ?
Mais c'est génial !
Vous irez prendre le chèque à la compta !
Et les clés de ma voiture aussi !
Wouh ! C'est parti ! Eh oui !
Regardez y a ma vidéo les gars là !
Mais non, c'est une pub !
Ben oui, c'est une pub que j'ai réalisée.
Vous aimez bien ?
- Ah...
- Ouais...
Une dune, un lion, un paysage...
Et là, paf ! Votre yahourt...
Ouais, enfin, moi je vend du parfum...
Et paf ! Votre parfum...
Hum, oui, champagne !
- Supprime !! Supprime !!
- Mais non ! Elle nous rapporte un max d'argent !!
On revient en France, mais on n'ouvre que 2 magasins.
Vous pensez vraiment que les gens vont faire la queue pendant 8 heures pour un putain d'hamburger ?!
Y a pas eu de mail !
Il a raison ! Il a raison !
Y a pas eu mail, il a raison !
Il a raison ! Il a raison ! Il a raison !
Il a raison ! Il a raison ! Ben il a raison !
Je vais l'avoir ! Je vais l'avoir !
Il avait raison, voilà !
TAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHH !!!
J'avais pensé à Pékin...
On parle tous dans notre barbe, dis-moi !
Oooh !
Depuis ce jour, Julien Josselin a changé de métier, il élève des bichons dans le Gers et a changé de sexe.
Il faut optimi... Non mais, mon gars...
Ah non, encore une pub !
Ah merde, j'allais vous rejoindre...
Elle a fait 200 vues !!
Woaaaaaaahhh !!!!
LE BUZZ !!! LE BUZZ !!!
T'es une star mon gars !
C'est une star !!
C'est une star !! C'est une star !!
J'enc*** une star !
Salut mon amour !
Aaah !! Aaaaaaahhhhh !!!!
Elle est belle ?
Salut mon amour !
Aaaaaaaaaaahhhh !!!!
Chanson : *lalalalalalala*
On couche ensemble ?
Ha ben oui ! Champagne alors, hein ?
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ? Pourquoi vous me faites ça ? C'est bizarre !
Aaaah ! Votre sexe est dans ma bouche, monsieur !
Monsieur ?...
SUPPRIME !!!
Elle nous rapporte un max d'argent !!
Un max de blé, mon gars !
Arrête ! Nan ! Laisse !
C'est bon!
C'est trop tard ! C'est trop tard !
Ok, ok, ok...
On a perdu les droits de diffusion pour les Simpsons !
Nan, je déconne ! Je déconne !
Non, je deconne pas !
Je déconne...
... pas du tout !
Peut-être que je déconne, on sait pas...
Il cuit des œufs !
Un écran plus grand !
- Un écran plus grand !
- Oh ! C'est bon ça !
- Ce mec est un génie !
- C'est comme ça qu'on pense chez Apple, merde !
Les mecs, vous avez pas vu Michel ?
Nan, il est en vacances.
Oh purée !
Salut Michel !
Eh, Michel !
Oui ?
Tu pourras venir ?
Non ! L'autre !
Oui !
Oui, Michel.
...dans les fesses, dans les fe...
Ah oui, dans les fesses ça rentre nickel !
...elle avait 3 seins, mon gars, elle avait...
Bah quoi ?
Hey, salut les mecs !
Oui d'accord !
Salut les mecs !
Non, mais la lettre U n'existe pas !
C'est n’importe quoi !
Et j’appelle tout de suite Gégé pour les réaliser,
et je perds mes lunettes. Allez salut !
Et puis comme ça on s'arrange bien, parce que...
Merde !
On a qu'une seule bouteille.
- On va me l'exploser sur la gueule, après c'est...
- Et on me l'a confiée à moi !
Et action !
Attends, attends, attends !
- On peut pas terminer tous nos gags par "champagne" !
- Ouais...
- Attends, on reprends !
- Oh, mec ! Me fais jamais ça, putain !
Mec, j'étais... euh... excité...
Champagne !
C'est douloureux quand même !
Ça va ?
Non.
Il m'a fait peur !